the ocean conveyor belt and the Gulf
Stream ocean currents have a direct
influence on our lives they determine
our weather our climate and much more
the ocean currents and wind systems
transport heat from the equator to the
poles and operate like a large engine
for the global climate in the oceans
there are numerous currents the so
called ocean conveyor belt is very
important for our climate this term
describes a combination of currents that
result in four of the five global oceans
exchanging water with each other they
form a worldwide circulation system the
conveyor belt is also called the
thermohaline circulation with thermo
referring to the temperature and hay
line to the salt content of the water
both determine the density of the water
while the masses of water may be moved
in part by wind primarily the different
densities of the global oceans are
responsible for their movement warm
water has a lower density and rises
while cold water sinks the water's
density also increases with a higher
salt content at the equator the heat
from the Sun is especially strong
resulting in a lot of evaporation and
thus arise in the waters salt content
that is where the Gulf Stream begins the
Gulf Stream is very important for the
European climate its length of 10,000
kilometers makes it one of the largest
and fastest ocean currents on earth and
it's very warm at roughly two metres a
second it brings up to 100 million cubic
meters of water per second towards
Europe
a constantly blowing wind the southeast
trade wind drives warm surface water to
the northwest into the Gulf of Mexico
where it heats up to 30 degrees Celsius
the turning of the earth and the west
winds then direct the Gulf Stream
towards Europe and split it up one part
flows south another east to the canary
current and a third part flows north
where it releases a lot of heat into the
atmosphere as the North Atlantic Current
the water becomes colder there its salt
content and density rise on account of
evaporation and it drops down between
Greenland Norway and Iceland there we
also find the largest waterfall on earth
the so called chimneys roughly 15
kilometre wide pillars with water
falling up to 4000 metres seventeen
million cubic meters of water per second
or roughly 15 times more water than is
carried by all the rivers in the world
this creates a strong Maelstrom which
constantly pulls in new water and is the
reason that the Gulf Stream moves
towards Europe countless species use the
Gulf Stream as a means of transport on
their trips from the Caribbean to
northern areas but it doesn't just bring
us animals an enormous quantity of warm
air also comes with it in order to
reduce the same heat which it brings to
the shores of Europe we would need 1
million nuclear power plants that's why
we also call the Gulf Stream a heat pump
without it the temperature would be
significantly colder here at least 5 to
10 degrees instead of lush fields we
would have long winters and sparse
ice-covered landscapes in Europe in the
last few years scientists and pundits in
the media have repeatedly expressed the
fear that the Gulf Stream could come to
a standstill due to climate change
because if the polar caps actually melt
the salt content in the water off
Greenland would fall as what its density
the North Atlantic Current would no
longer be heavy enough and so it
wouldn't sink as usual in the worst case
that would bring the Gulf Stream our
heat pump to a stop some climate experts
also assume that climate change could
compensate for this effect we know that
it can be normal for the climate to
change by looking at the development of
the earth over the last few million
years there are ice ages and warm
periods in the last ice age a gigantic
flood of melting water crippled the heat
bringing North Atlantic Current covering
the northern hemisphere in ice
scientists have different views on the
impact that climate change will have on
the global ocean conveyor belt but one
thing is clear when the climate changes
then the complex system of ocean
currents and winds which has remained
fairly stable since the last ice age
will change in ways that we don't yet
understand
you